yes it's a it's a pleasure to be here
thank you leslie we've known each other
for almost seven or eight years now and
we're trying to work together to
possibly do some of the research that
that is I feel is a key to helping out
our climate issue and we're trying to
actually place some of the fabrics that
she's working with up in a true
environment where where we feel that
it'll actually have some great impact up
on the arctic ocean and and I've been
going to both poles north and south for
quite some time it's been a remarkable
journey I didn't think that I was going
to get into climate change ever it sort
of been sort of happened by accident and
certainly fun so this is an interesting
photo this was taken in 1972 it's called
the Blue Marble you guys have seen it's
probably the most published picture of
our ever it was taken by one of the last
Apollo trips I think Apollo 17 maybe but
you know i remember in 1972 when that
picture was taken and it was it was
published i looked at it and really had
a good idea of wow this is this is what
our planet looks like when when the sun
is fully hitting it and you know i
didn't know that we were able to destroy
our planet that quickly from 72 so you
guys are a future and we need to do
something about it now and hopefully you
guys can come up with some ways that we
can curb our our carbon use and try to
go with more renewables july 2015 was
the hottest month ever recorded 2015 is
on on track to be the hottest year ever
there was also shows a little bit of
diagram global temperature by decades
and how it is unanimous that that we're
getting warmer also the globe and carbon
carbon emissions through fossil fuels
has been increasing since the Industrial
Revolution and this is the cause of a
man-made pollution that were that we're
seeing and doing
this is sort of a comparison of our co2
concentration as well as the temperature
and just shows a graph on you know our
co2 emissions and then our temperature
range going up as well and these are all
the things that that are wear to the
greenhouse gases come from there's coal
plants industrial process there's
farming there's fertilization there's
transportation there's all these
different things that are causing it and
I'm just a skier I'm not a scientist I'm
not an engineer and I've been going out
on the planet going too far reaches the
planet just going to ski and I love
skiing i love i own a company called ice
axe expeditions and what we do is human
powered skiing so we climb everything
and then we ski down so it's really
important for me to be able to do more
human powered I don't use helicopters I
don't use snowmobiles it's just I'm
usually on a sailboat or a boat and I
get off the boat and climb up and then
ski back down it's just all I like to do
is leave it leave a set of ski tracks
and I've skied all over the world's fall
barred Antarctica i leave for Antarctica
and another week and a half I'm really
looking forward to that's my 19th trip
to the Antarctic Peninsula my 38th trip
to Antarctica and I've been going back
and back every every every year and I've
been seeing a lot of differences also
bring my paddle board with me I don't
know if you guys are familiar with
stand-up paddling i love the paddle this
is uh this is actually up in Svalbard
and this is actually in Antarctica on a
beautiful day and it's just a great way
to see the environment you're able to
see the seals and the penguins and
through the water and the water is quite
clear too so it's a great way to just
see things but I guess I sort of started
my engineering early this was early 2003
january 2003 i designed what i call what
they now call the ice bike and it was a
bike to go across Antarctica i was going
for three weeks and i wanted to go
around the heritage range and i wanted
to see if I could do this trip across
the across the heavy snow and I put a
sled
I actually designed it so it would be
attached to the back back axle which was
a bad decision he much better to
actually attach it to the seat post and
I made these big fat tires I beveled the
tires i used front fork suspension
systems in a seat post suspension so i
could go across the ice and what I
didn't realize is I got hit with an
atypical storm off the weddell sea and
grounded me for five days straight I
couldn't move I was hit with 150 mile an
hour winds I had to go outside the tent
every two or three hours to dig myself
out so I wasn't buried alive and 45 days
I had to do this and so I started seeing
and as you don't know Antarctica gets
about 12 inches of snow a year and I got
hit with a 32 inch storm so as I'm going
to Antarctica I'm seeing different
weather patterns happen and it's sort of
alarming to me to see this but my first
trip to Antarctica was in 1999 I wanted
to go climb and ski and snowboard the
highest peak in Antarctica and so I went
to the Vinson Massif it's 16,000 77 feet
this is on her summit ridge I ended up
going over to climb this mountain this
is the sixth highest peak called Mount
shin and then the second highest peak is
right over here called Mount Tyree and I
named my son after that one and I'd like
to go back and ski it with him at some
point in time in the future after that
trip to Vincent it was we were hit with
another a typical storm of like I think
30 inches of snow again so I had visions
of us skiing ice and technical tools to
be able to get down and we had Antarctic
powder so um that was sort of alarming
to me I thought you said there was only
12 inches a year and we got 30 inches in
one storm but anyway about about eight
months after that first trip I was asked
to glomp asked to guide a blind
gentleman and a deaf gentleman across
Antarctica from the coast of Antarctica
787 miles to the south pole so I had
never done anything like this before so
through this process I learned a lot
about myself first of all I had to
figure out a way to keep him safe he
doesn't have use of his eyes
and then his site guy John Cook the guy
next to him he's deaf so I have a I have
a blind gentleman and a deaf gentleman
and I'm going to go do something that
I've never ever done before so we set
off and I tried a few different things I
had a bell on the back of my sled and I
would be skiing the first hour I think
and I look behind me and miles is the
name of the gentleman who's blind he's
off skiing into the best the wind was so
strong he couldn't hear the bell behind
me so I had to go unhook myself in the
sled go chase him down bring him back
and then I had to ski next to him for
seven hundred and eighty seven miles to
me and what there was and the snow there
was things called sis Trudy that's
caused by wind and so you would triple
he would trip over this sister oogie
pieces so what I would do is sort of
push him around it or I'd pull him
around this is Trudy so he wouldn't fall
and I really have to give it to him I
tried to ski for about a hundred yards
and I fell over three or four times so
and I shut my eyes and try to do it so I
really had to give it to him and and for
him to be successful I had to keep him
safe you know if he if he got frostbite
or injured during the trip it was a
no-win situation especially for me but
also for him to I didn't want that to
happen so there's a lot of things that
you have to go through to make sure that
that he is safe and this is a gentleman
ernest shackleton he's one of my heroes
and Shackleton was a turn-of-the-century
explore in 1909 he got within ninety
seven miles of the South Pole and had
the ability to say oh my gosh we don't
have enough food and fuel we can't
continue we need to go back these guys
at this time would take four years of
their life to go on and to mount an
expedition like this and it would take
almost a year and a half for them to
sail from England to get to the right
spot they'd win her over and then start
the expedition and then have to return
and then pretty much win her over again
and then actually head back so a lot of
respect for these guys in 1914 through
1916 we're coming into the 100 year
anniversary of Shackleton's Imperial
trans antarctic expedition what
Shackleton tried to do he tried to come
into the weddell sea here the roni Ice
Shelf get to about Berkner Island and
then he wanted to ski to the South Pole
and then down to McMurdo Sound there's
actually permanent ice here and
no dice here a lot of people don't
realize that the the ice expands around
Antarctica almost 500 miles every winter
and they just had some tests or some
researchers have some studies saying
this year was actually a pretty big ice
year was one of the biggest ice years
they've had in about 25 years but what
shackled one do want to come into the
roni ice shelf or the weddell sea and he
wanted to win her over Berkner island or
lever glacier somewhere around there and
then start his journey the next spring
what happened i'll tell the story real
quick the boat came in crushed the boat
he camped next to the boat as the ice
moving out to sea for two months finally
the boat sunk right off of Elephant
Island right here they had a couple row
boats they took all their supplies to
Elephant Island dropped off 22 men and
then Shackleton sales from Elephant
Island all the way way off them off the
map to a place called the island of
South Georgia 800 miles away got to the
wrong side of the island had to climb
over had no climbing gear no food no
tents took 36 hours to go climb over the
island to get to the other side where
there was some whaling stations they
ended up getting to the wrong whaling
station which was for tuna and then
climbing back up the hill to get to the
right one which was stromness it was a
complete epic journey Worsley the
Navigator was able to find this needle
in a haystack the island 800 miles away
was able to navigate in a little tiny
20-foot rowboat so they end up sailing
about 1,700 miles back to Punta Arenas
Chile took six months for the money to
get to the Queen of England to say hey I
got men stuck in Antarctica please send
money so I can buy a boat six months for
money to get back and then he was set
sail he bought a boat and set sail to go
down to rescue all his men and the boat
got crushed off at Cape Horn he returns
to to Puntarenas he asked the the
Chilean Navy please can I borrow boat so
they gave him a tugboat that really
wasn't even suitable to leave Harbor and
he was going all the way to Antarctica
across the roughest see in the world the
Drake Passage to go rescue every one of
his men they lived on penguin and seal
for 22 months he rescued every one of
those men so he's one of my heroes
uh 2007 I wanted to go see if I could do
the journey that he intended to do I got
dropped off right by Berkner Island and
I skied 47 days 47 days 737 miles to the
south pole and that was probably from
here all the way to here the miles route
with the blind guy we left from a place
called here called Hercules Inlet and
that's 787 miles to the south pole and
that took me 62 days and so you don't
realize but you're really on these polar
expeditions you wear the same underwear
every day you basically every week you
turn it inside out or right side in and
then you another week will go by and
then you change it up I only carry the
things that you absolutely need you only
carry the food and fuel you wear the
same clothes I cut my toothbrush in half
I cut labels out of clothing it's very
very important that you only carry the
necessities so I do that with my Arctic
trips to but I just wanted to give you a
map of Antarctica to see I didn't take a
boat like Shackleton I fly in with a
elution aircraft and land on the ice
runway which is pretty remarkable in its
own right and then we took a dc-3 with
skis you can see the skis down here and
we got dropped off at the basically the
filter ice shelf and this is me and my
client and you can see these aren't
mountains behind this is actually
upheaval of ice ice is moving curve
haces are forming and you can see our
tracks as we come around here and what I
do is you can see these tracks right
here I actually run ahead and set up a
tripod with the camera and then I run
back and get in the camera into the
picture takes but you can actually see
the the crevasses behind us during that
journey I think I fell into four
different crevices up to my chest and
was able to extract myself luckily and
was able to continue the journey but
this is a good picture because if you
look in the background you could see how
the ice undulates and every day I would
gain more and more altitude and within
the first I'd say two weeks we gained
over 9,000 feet or 3000 meters and then
you're up on the polar plot
from there it's pretty much a straight
shot right to the pole so it was an
uphill but it wasn't that much it
undulates light slightly you can see
this is true ghee in the in the ice we
had a lot of whiteout conditions a lot
of time you couldn't see anything in
front of you i had to use ways of
navigation usually when the Sun is out
you can use your body like almost like a
compass or basically your shadow just
comes around your body and you're able
to navigate exactly where you know where
South is when it's white out it becomes
difficult you can see I have a little
flag that's taped to my pole and I use
that as a navigation tool I can actually
get my compass out and find out where
we're south is and I'm able to even if I
can't see my skis or my hand I can put
that up to my face and actually see the
direction that that wind is is going and
then a few times a day i'll double check
it with a GPS coordinate but uh but most
the time I'm just got my compass out and
i'm using the wind socks to be able to
navigate another picture of us
navigating you can see me pulling my
compass out all the time everything that
we need is in that sled and we use some
too I mean technology has come a long
way and this is actually 2007 I have a
little iphone in AU ridium satellite
phone and I can update my my Instagram
and Facebook and all that kind of good
stuff every day and you know so I can be
in touch with the outside world and
sponsors can follow and get some media
out of it so that was part of our daily
process at the end of the day you know
you're so exhausted from skiing 14 15
hours a day we were still doing you know
dispatches and blogs and stuff like that
and you can see I have tape on my nose
that's not because I injured myself that
is more preventative maintenance and
what I have to do is I would be sweating
and my put my goggles on and I'd have to
take my goggles off and the my goggles
would freeze to my face and pull about
15 layers of skin off my nose in my
cheeks so I would just put tape there to
make sure that I didn't get a taken but
after 47 days and we made it to the
South Pole I had a few injuries I think
before that I mean on the way I think I
got snow blind
I also had to pull one of my molars out
I was eating a piece of chocolate so
imagine you living in a freezer
everything around you all the food is
frozen and I just had a little tiny
piece of chocolate and I shoved into my
mouth and I end up breaking the tooth
and I had to pull it out with like a
leatherman tool or a needle nose plier
so I had a bunch of gauze there and I
end up getting snow blind because my
goggles froze shut and I couldn't
actually navigate for several hours so i
ended up for the last three days i think
i just had to sort of walk by braille to
get there but it was a after about five
or six days i was able to continue so
this was me before the trip started wait
about 217 pounds as I'm going into these
trips I'm trying to gain a bunch of
weight i'm actually eating you know
three or four things of Ben and Jerry's
and a couple chicken rotisserie Zand you
know I even donuts I don't even like
donuts and I fattening food because I
want to try to gain some weight but when
I got there I weighed 170 for and that's
why I have the patch on because I was
snowblind you can see I have a little
bit of swollen asst in my cheek from
pulling my tooth out and I don't bring a
comb so i had to shape my head was all
dreaded so i had to shave my head as
well but you can see I look like a
concentration camp victim but in 2010 a
friend of mine grant Corrigan is on the
left and his wife Shauna came to me and
asked me to do an expedition to the
South Pole and this is another guy that
in March of 2010 I'm sorry this is 2012
we actually did the trip but 2010 he was
in a snowmobile accident in the snore
mountains of California and he was
trying to do a big huge gap jump or just
jump with a snowmobile and he overshot
the gap jump and landed 150 feet
straight down to this to the snow and
broke his l 6 + l7 which is his lumbar 6
and 7 and the doctor said he would never
walk again and his wife he was married
to Shawna about two months prior to that
accident and she said she would stand by
him when he couldn't stand for himself
so basically grant came to me and said
hey I want to do a trip to the South
Pole and so we had to come up with ways
an engineer a way for him to get to the
pole so what we did is we engineered a
thing called a sit ski and so we went
through several different models we went
through ones with suspension and non
suspension and skinny skis and so the
most durable one we found had a really
rigid body we used normal skis with no
skins or anything and we even tested
with him trying to push with the sled
and then the most efficient way is truly
without a sled and you think about
skiing and you think about snow and you
think about gliding well up on the polar
plateau it's so cold it's probably minus
40 degrees Celsius and Fahrenheit they
converge at the same place you think
this crystals are so large and they're
so cold that you basically there's no
glide it's as grant put it I think it's
like styrofoam and velcro is how he
described it it'd be like going trying
to push across this carpet on skis so
you can imagine that effort that it
would take to go 76 miles across the the
polar plateau and and what was really
interesting for me as a as a guide I had
to make sure just like i did with miles
i had to make sure that he was safe how
am I going to get someone who can't feel
his feet get him across the South Pole
because he wouldn't be able to tell me
if his feet are getting cold I certainly
can tell when my feet are getting cold i
would say okay my feet are getting cold
i need to jump around or do something
about it or getting a tent or or put
heat warmers or something like that he
can't tell me so we had to design thermo
couplers that are temperature gauges
that we taped to his toes and we ran
cables up his leg and then we had a
little temperature gauge on his stomach
and so every hour I would check that out
at one time during the trip it got to 27
degrees that's below freezing so we had
to set up the tent stop right away and
we came up with some other methods we
had other ways to be able to
problem-solve to make sure that we were
able to get safely one of the things was
we got him out of the boots we put we
put some foot bed warmers in some other
hand warmers on his feet and we actually
use what's called an elephant's foot
which is basically half a sleeping bag
you cut a sleeping bag in half and you
just put it on while he's pushing so
both those things really worked and we
were able to continue I was the lead
guide on the thing and what grant wanted
to do this is the pole itself in the the
original twelve Antarctic Treaty
countries are our flags that are
displayed right at the at the ceremonial
pole he wanted to get out he's actually
healing he trains about eight or nine
hours a day and he wanted to ski the
last hundred feet to the South Pole and
so I got him out of the sit ski he's I'm
standing next to and make sure he
doesn't fall over he's skin he's crying
as he's walking through the flags and
he's just looks at me and he says I wish
my wife was here to see this beautiful
moment of my life and we secretly flew
her in to the South Pole so we actually
she flew in she actually walked up and
took her goggles off and said welcome to
the South Pole and we made a movie about
it called the push it'll be out this
fall Morgan Freeman's narrating it we're
trying to get academy screening and it's
going to be in Sundance and few other
things so it's called the push and so
keep an eye out for it just last year I
was involved in an expedition actually
this was two expeditions in one because
we're flying into that ice runway at
Union glacier and we're going to take a
six by six artic truck all the way
across Antarctica and this was going to
be interesting because I've always flown
I've skied I've done all these different
things across Antarctica but this trip
was actually we're going to drive all
the way to the South Pole and then all
the way down to the filter ice shelf and
that was where we're going to start
because remember this is all sea ice
that's considered land and that's all
see is one and when we're looking at
that other picture of Antarctica so
we're considering this is the coast of
Antarctica even though there's about
about a hundred and thirty feet of ice
between that and ground but you could
see a couple crevices and you can see
some water down there so they call it
land so that's where we actually drove
across and we were going to do some we
were doing some climate-change research
I was going with a young lad from the
Yale
and he was 18 years old and he had been
on three other expeditions to the North
Pole with me but I wanted to he been
sort of his mentor and we were doing
some really cool science work we were
collecting collecting isotopes as well
as doing a bunch of core samples as well
which was a lot a lot of fun so here's
Parker on the left and i'm on the right
and we're just having a little dinner in
the tent and talking about our day and
you can see this is the truck that we
took in how rough it was the cruise
across and and i was of course up front
to make sure if we ran into any crevices
and fell the wheels fell into any curve
haces we had a winch up here and i could
make an anchor and we could get it out
so we really put a lot of thought into
traveling across this remote tundra and
then we put a box in the back and a lot
of the guys even Parker had to stay in
the back for a lot of it and that was a
that would have been miserable I always
said I had to be up front because make
sure we didn't fall in any curve haces
but we we stopped every I'd say every 80
miles and we dug big huge pits that
certainly got you warm even in super
cold temperatures and that was a lot of
work and also we did core samples which
we had a boring core displacement tool
that we were able to get core samples
and then we were putting them in Pelican
cases to make sure that we could collect
the data a lot of the time it doesn't
show in this picture but we would have
huge huge hazmat suits on to make sure
that we were doing it accurately weren't
contaminating the samples at all so I
think we had some hazmat suits and we're
wearing gloves and stuff like that so it
was always interesting to collect data
but then we started from the levirate
and it was about four hundred and thirty
eight miles and we end up doing that
trip in 18 days four hours and 43
minutes the previous record was 24 days
so we pretty much smashed the record and
it still stands today so certainly had a
great time doing it with Parker and I've
had other clients that have come back to
me and said hey I want to go beat the
record not basically say hey you need to
raise money for charity or come up with
a
I'm sort of caused to do it or I'm not
taking you and that's really my policy
with almost all my trips and then I in
about a week and a half I'm going to
sail from Ushuaia Argentina which is in
the beagle channel and we'll sail 600
miles to the western side of the
peninsula and I operate I sacks
expeditions which is asked we do human
powered skiing and will Skee in the
Antarctic Peninsula and we have to cross
the Drake Passage I've done 32 crossings
16 have been pretty much Drake lake in
16 of Britain Drake shake and I'd say
four of those 16 that were Drake shake
were hurricane-force winds so I'm hoping
that it's a smooth one everyone else is
hoping that there's a big one because
they want to have a big storm across the
Drake and the boats super safe but i'd
rather be smooth i do live feeds from
antarctica to classrooms in the United
States and Canada where I've pioneered
the technology so this is another thing
that I've done which is a has I've
tested the boundaries and the parameters
of where these inmarsat iridium and
uranium in inmarsat locators can go from
they go down from almost 70 degrees
south and almost 70 degrees north so I
can actually do a live feed from
northern Greenland or middle of
Greenland and all the way down to the
Antarctic Peninsula this adelie penguin
just happened to just show up on cue
someone said cue the Adelie penguin and
he jumps up right in front of me and I
have a camera and I'm talking to
students and of course the students are
screaming and yelling and it's it's just
a great learning experience I love
seeing how the students that want to be
engaged and they're able to ask me
questions live how old is that penguin
that's pecking at your boot oh well it's
about six weeks old it's going to take
another few weeks for it to lose all its
feathers before it can go hunt for
itself so it's a very cool interactive
stuff I really love doing the ones down
in Antarctica and also up in the in the
Brazilian Amazon I do some trips up
there and i'll have my guides collect a
giant river turtle an anaconda sloth and
some bullet ants and then i'll have some
students even sometimes with me and
we'll pull that out to be able to
interact with the with the students it's
point
quite fun and on this pedestal you can
actually see the began satellite
communicator i can put everything in my
backpack and carry it to the top of
Everest or just ash or a few penguins
around there's the boat there so I can
have a high speed connection pretty much
anywhere on the planet and use solar
panels to charge it and all that kind of
good stuff in a penguin rookery but the
beauty of the Antarctic Peninsula is
unsur mounted I mean it's just just
total beauty these these glaciers are
calving there's about seven or eight
that are calving at an alarming rate
most of them are on the eastern side of
that Antarctic Peninsula I go more on
the west there's more Mountains there
there are glaciers that are calving but
not as many as the on the eastern side
because uh the ice sheet is actually
calving there's huge icebergs the size
of Rhode Island in Manhattan that are
just calving off and there the tabular
ones there the tabular icebergs that are
calving off so there's I'd say
Antarctica is about ninety percent of
the world's ice it's about seventy
percent of the world's freshwater a lot
of people don't realize that so there's
a lot of glaciation that's happening and
we're taking skiers we travel with ropes
some of the technology i'm working with
MIT with a device called a Patek I mean
I still am NOT can place and I dig snow
pits I use you know I'm analyzing the
snowpack i'm using my mountain sense i
call it i'm actually you know as I'm
touring up mountains I'm looking at
where the Sun is hitting and where wind
loading is happening in in different
aspects of the terrain because I
certainly don't want to have a death
wish I want to be able to travel in the
mountain safely but this is a new device
that just came out about a year and a
half ago and it's called Avva tech some
MIT graduates have a probe and they'll
put it down in the snow and they'll find
the weak layers and not only does it
detect where the leak layers is it'll
pick up the data to a website so the
community can follow and learn from it
as well so it's actually a really cool
tool and
I've been helping them out with some
stuff and if you want to have some more
information I can give you some more
information about it after the thing but
but I'm down there to check out the
Penguins chinstrap penguins these are
gentoo penguins it's definitely a little
bit odiferous and these are some gentoos
and this is a chick in a mom or dad
feeding the chick and like I said a few
minutes ago it takes about nine weeks
for them to lose all their feathers
before they can actually jump in the
water and hunt for themselves do any of
it you go on to them yeah there's it
there's an antarctic treaty that says
you're supposed to be within five meters
or 15 feet from any wildlife but if you
sit there you're not a predator for any
of those animals it they'll come right
up to you they love those little tassels
on your ski jacket or your ski pants
they'll come right up to you and peck at
you and you're not supposed to pet them
or anything but they're very very
friendly and I mean if you skied it into
a bunch of penguins I'm sure they're
going to like you know fly try to fly
away or just run away and be stressed
out we try not to step in any big post
holing you know what post holding is
when you step in snow and you go all the
way up to your knee if a penguin fell in
there that would stress the penguin out
and probably couldn't get out and maybe
die so you even like when I leave a
penguin rookery I even walked backwards
and sort of cover the big holes that I'm
making with my boots to make sure that
they're not falling in and can you tell
which one's the the chick in the adult
pretty easy and then there's leopard
seals this is one of the only predators
for the for the Penguins but they've
really probably never run into a leopard
seal before either and so there's plenty
of penguins and certainly plenty of
leopard seals for them to eat there's
elephant seals I don't always agree with
these guys dating habits they usually
have about 30 girlfriends and then
another male will approach the beach and
you can actually see how beat up this
one is because it was in a fight with
another male or several other males and
then
and then what will happen is the winner
will actually retain the harem and then
the other ones will go back to see and
look for another male 2 to fight and
have dominance there's killer whales
down there we ran into a pack of about
seven of these they were attacking a
seal and they won and it's it's really
interesting to watch how they work
together to be able to to knock it off
the iceberg too and that was really
interesting to watch that happen it
wasn't you know it's it's life it
happens but I find clothes crevices this
one was like 100 feet long and it had a
floor in it and also ceiling with 35
foot walls and you can ski all the way
through it I also do a lot of work up
north going north now and the you had a
picture dr. Fields had a picture of the
North Pole with the the losing of the
sea ice and I've been working up here
since almost two thousand three I do a
lot of trips out of Svalbard i work in
Greenland mostly down here in this
western side of Greenland the hakama
sovereign glacier is the one that you've
been seeing and chasing ice in the one
that like calves off the size of I think
Manhattan holcomb chobham great Chavan
glacier in alula SAT and I've been
working there the last couple summers I
also attempting this this coming summer
I have a client that wants to try to
sail through the Northwest Passage and
we'll probably have to go through here
and here and here and then out through
there so it's going to take us about six
weeks to do that almond scent a hundred
years ago took them three years there's
only been about sixty boats to ever get
through so hopefully we can hopefully
it's a I mean it's hopefully we can't
really because I'm hoping that there's a
lot of ice the reason I'm showing you
this I work a lot up here and in 2005 I
left from a little island right there
called kapok to chesky it took me on
almost a month to get across Russia from
Moscow to cross knee hasta hoy tengo tu
a little meaty rod meteorological
station called go Leon E and then I
finally got to this little island
called que parte de cesky and for the
first two days of that journey the ice
was so thin I saw it flex in front of me
I was certainly scared we never stopped
we just kept on going for two days
straight we started on march first and
there's only about five hours of light
at this time of year so every day we
were getting almost 40 more minutes of
light so we had headlamps on we couldn't
really see too much the ice was super
thin my fear was that one of us would
fall in and then it would be a chain
reaction where we would continue to fall
in and everybody would fall in and and
so 2006 I did the trip and we finally
did find some solid ice and we can't we
were camped although when we when we set
camp I tried to get some ice and snow to
boil in our stove to create water so we
can eat and drink and the ice that I had
gotten was too fresh it had too much
salt saline content and a too much salt
so we basically had the condensation
inside the tent I took a pot in a pot
lid and scrape scrape the inside of the
tent and that's all we had to drink for
really two and a half days but 2006 was
the last successful attempt from que
parte cesky 2007 two people two
individuals attempted to ski from from
the Cape to the South Pole and both of
them were rescued one of them died and
there hasn't been any buddy attempting
it because as you saw in dr. Fields
slide there is no sea ice in the even in
the in the spring so most the trips are
going from either Greenland er ward hunt
Island which is right here that's where
Perry one of our famous explorers who
got to the North Pole first that's where
he left from cape discoveries another
place that it was left and that's
actually on Greenland as well so
and that is that why you care about I
citizen just because we love ice and
skiing and the polar bears though all
that's true about a third of global
temperature rise is being attributed to
this ice disappearance because we're
reflecting the heat the Summer Sun so
much less now that's gone so well let me
just add to that it's actually the
reflection means albedo and what that is
is if there's sea ice there it's going
to reflect off the ice surface and cool
our planet when you have open water or
more open water and this is some of the
observations that I've been seeing if
you have more open water it's going to
absorb that water is saline and it's
dark and it absorbs and it's going to
change the temperature that water that
that that water that's visible to the
Sun will warm up very quickly and will
melt other ice around it and jot and
dive deep and head toward the equator
and then that warm equatorial water sort
of heads toward the equator or heads
toward the poles so you have this
cyclical movement of water which is
called the Gulf Stream if you change the
temperature even a half a degree from
you have a more open water huge impacts
and I'm talking about more intense
storms there's actually been less storms
less hurricanes coming through or I'm
sorry less there's a hurricane season
down in the Caribbean and them and then
Atlantic there's been less storms but 10
times more intense so you're seeing a
lot more damage that's happening you're
also seeing superstorm sandy and Katrina
and so these storms are becoming more
intensified because it's pulling up more
warmer water from the oceans so yeah
that's that's definitely happening and
so 2005 I did the poll track which was
an international scientific expedition
and I wanted to do something for science
I didn't want to just go and beat my
chest and so the scientists who I worked
with from Alpha venga Institute
University of Ottawa University of
Washington some of the most noted
climate change scientists on the planet
handed me
50 pound beacon remember earlier I was
telling you how I cut labels out of
clothing in my toothbrush in half and
and how they wanted me to take ten of
these beacons with me across the Arctic
Ocean I didn't say no but I I sort of
took it apart I looked at what they what
the instruments were and I got together
with my two friends and we redesigned
the beacon to weigh about seven pounds
as opposed to 50 and we took three of
them and two of them are still working
today one of them sunk but really that's
what I'm proud of its it's about they
all had carbon fiber tubing they were
actually more accurate than the ones
that the scientists were using because
what they were doing is drop in these
boxes out of airplanes to places they've
never been to we were going somewhere
what they have never been to but we were
actually installing I'm setting them up
finding really good solid multi-year ice
to put these beacons on to be able so
they could collect out and they were
actually a lot more accurate than the
ones that they were using prior to that
so it's really interesting and I'm not a
scientist I'm just a knucklehead and you
just sort of say okay this this is a GPS
device this is a uranium modem that will
pick up data three times a day this is
the temperature gauge this is the it's
simple it's not like it's really hard to
do but now the Arctic buoy program is
using a beacon I design so these are the
beacons you can see pretty simple all
the devices and all the instruments are
down in here you know all the
temperature gauges and all that is up
here this is after 52 days on the ice
and if you look this is me on the Left
we have these big huge himalayan down
jackets that are supposed to be super
puffy and keep you warm well what
happens it's because we're at sea level
and it's very humid environment so
everything is soggy I remember after
about two weeks into the trip took us 52
days but two weeks into the trip I had
to I was picking up my sleeping bag and
put it into my sled and I was like why
is this for pound three-pound sleeping
bag way like 20 pounds what's in it cuz
I always putting stuff at the bottom of
the sleep
but I reached down to the bottom it was
all ice because I had what's called a
vapor barrier liner but it must have had
a hole in it or whatever because I said
formed inside the down sleeping bag or
it was synthetic I'm sorry but it had
formed so I had to cut open the sleeping
bag and try to pull all the ice out to
make it so it was a lot less weight
because I were trying to get rid of
weight you know every day that we eat
and we drink we're using fuel and where
he's in food our sled should get lighter
but I had it I was hauling around a
20-pound sleeping bag but we also did
snow depth measurements and ice depth
measurements and I try to incorporate
science work with almost every trip that
I do it's really important to me to try
to bring back down in and after skiing
for 1415 hours a day the last thing you
want to do is go out there for an hour
and collect data but it was super
important to make sure that we are
collecting the right information and
doing it accurately otherwise our our
research in our data collection would
been worthless but this is typical
Arctic Ocean the ice is constantly
moving and you could see some old
pressure ridges here and people ask me
all the time what is what's happening on
the Arctic Ocean you know what are you
seeing and to be honest I'm seeing a lot
less multi-year ice and when I say multi
rice I'm talking probably four to 14
years old I consider that multi-year ice
I'm seeing second year single year ice
I'm seeing a lot of that it's actually
gotten easier for me to ski the pole
when I do like a last degree which is
about 70 miles so this is alarming to me
and I'm seeing huge differences up there
I'm seeing a lot more open water i'm
seeing a typical storms it's usually
pretty stable conditions i'm seeing more
storms and i'm trying it's harder for us
to find a lot of that multi-year ice and
so a lot of that multi area ice multi
your ice is being pushed down to the
bath and straights and toured canada and
so I have a few slides to share with you
about that but this is a freshwater lead
and you can see the salt crystals
forming it only takes several hours it's
probably minus thirty
minus 40 so in salt water freezes at 32
degrees or zero Celsius it freezes
pretty pretty pretty quickly within a
couple hours it when it freezes it what
it does is it matrix is it actually
becomes really really strong and for me
I'm always on skis I can almost ski
across it within a couple hours of fresh
ice freezing so it shouldn't take that
long and here's another picture of me
actually probably the first the second
week of the 2005 trip and you can see
how low the Sun is and you can't have
any skin exposed we have special poles
we use I designed the sleds the sleds
have Kevlar fabric on the top so you
could you can ski across and you can't
poke it with a knife or a ski pole
everything it has to take we design our
stoves differently we're designing
clothing with the clothing companies
we're working with boot companies to
make this stuff so this is really a lot
of the fun that I have is really it's
not like you can go to rei and just say
hey I want the polar polar gear you know
so it's been fun to work with a lot of
companies to try to design and and make
stuff that works in the polar
environments and so that's been a real
pleasure to do and it's not really good
for the open market like a lot of people
aren't buying these type of things but
they're certainly interested in the
impact and the knowledge that we that we
that we give and you do see some of it
implant implemented in some of the
clothing like I do a lot of what's
called body mapping because I consider
my activity an aerobic activity but I'm
in minus 40 degree temperatures so you
need to regulate your perspiration so
what happens is you're you're generating
huge amounts of energy by pulling a 300
pound sled and you're sweating but you
don't want to sweat so I don't wear that
much clothing i wear maybe a gore-tex
jacket and then I wear like a wool top
and then when I stop I put on the big
down jacket just keep me warm and that's
what I do I mean and then I'm cold after
about five minutes my hands are freezing
and I want to get going again and soon
as I've five minutes in
getting going I'm actually okay and
that's my that's my safe place my safe
place is actually when I'm moving and
skiing across the ice or in the tent in
the sleeping bag and we run into polar
bears I think they're they say there's
about twenty five thousand polar bears
around the Arctic Ocean they usually are
close to the shore and they'll go out to
the sea ice looking for seals and I've
encountered quite a few those especially
when you're on the coast like this one
trip that I did in 05 we ran into 19
different polar bears and they aren't
very friendly then they're not real
friendly because they've never seen
humans before they're quite fast they
probably run about 25 miles an hour they
swim real fast to the males are really
interesting they do what's called a
walking slumber for two months they'll
still lower their metabolism down and
they'll sleep walk the females will dig
a cave and actually give birth to two to
three cubs about I'd say every two or
three years these Cubs are probably
about two months old to three months old
and they're quite cute but I don't think
they were that cute I had a few polar
bear encounters this is what they eat
this is bearded seals and they are
actually have really strong claws and
what they'll do is they'll make air
holes they can only stay underneath the
eyes for about 22 minutes this is a
typical picture of old consolidated
multi or ice you can see how well i call
it rubble terrain and it might take us
you know an hour to go 100 yards here's
another picture this is near canada and
this is a trip i did there and you could
see all this multi or ice and we use two
small sleds and I'd pull one about a
quarter mile and then I have to come
back and get the other one so you didn't
make a lot of progress you can see the
land that's actually a Canada right
there and so for I'd say about 40 miles
you have to go through this because of
all that multi-year ice being pushed
down toward bath and straight so that's
a good depiction of and it's definitely
a lot of hard work and there's polar
bears they're so a lot of this going on
you know they can be 30 feet high and
you have to really be on it you're
exhausted you're tired you got
make sure the sled doesn't come down and
get you in the ankle and the expedition
is over so you always have to be honest
it's one of those things where your
focus has to be 24 7 and you have to be
focused throughout the entire expedition
you guys can actually go home tonight
you can get a book out lie on the couch
and sort of turn off I could I can't do
that and it's really one of those things
where you're tapping into two twelve
thirteen fourteen percent of your brain
and you're completely focused and almost
to the point where you don't want it to
end it's your so it's so civilized it's
such a civilized way of life every day
as you get up at the same time your mind
actually gets up at the same time I
don't use even alarm clock or anything i
get up at the same time I boil my water
I eat I drink I pack up my stuff and I'm
out of the ten at a certain time every
day and just trying to ski across and
then you get to your goal you get to the
pole you almost do want to do more you
want to keep on going in a really
strange way that doesn't sound like you
know you're not really celebrating you
just want to keep on going but typical
see Isis is some multi-year ice I'd say
that's probably about three or four
years old you can see how it freezes and
the multiple layers that keep on
happening every snowstorm and then it
gets condensed but you're jumping from
lily pad to lily pad you're using the
sleds the sleds actually float i used a
dutch design company and that makes
kayaks and how did we drop these these
sleds from a second-story window at 250
pounds in them so we knew that they were
going to withstand some abuse i think i
told you there was a there was a kevlar
fabric and i'll tell you one quick polar
bear story i was in the tent we would
rock paper scissors to see who would
sleep in the middle there was three of
us i was sleeping in the middle these
guys were snoring and i couldn't believe
it i hear a polar bear right outside the
tent really as close as me to the screen
right here and i unzip the tent i hope i
got a flare gun out and I hit him square
between the eyes you know because he
looked over at me and he had ripped open
the sled like it was tissue paper and
was eating my food so and then these
guys I shot the bear the
ran away and then these guys got up and
said what are you doing so we also use
dry suits a lot of the time you know the
leads are so long and so wide and so
distant that you just put on a dry suit
and you swim across another picture of
us I had a rope where I attached it to
the sled to bring the sled across and
you just sort of backstroke it wouldn't
support our weight so we just have to
swim across and then you pull off the
dry suit as soon as you get out of the
out of the water it pretty much freezes
because it's minus 40 and you just brush
off the all the ice off the dry suit and
you put it in the sled and start moving
again what can we do well there's a lot
we can do the Hawaiian legislature has
approved a bill requiring Hawaii to
generate a hundred percent of its
electric electricity from renewables by
2045 I think they should try to do it to
2030 that's what the UN council was was
talking about last about two weeks ago
there their goal is to 30 Hawaii's
making a try to do it by 2045 Morocco
has wind farms there's also off of the
coast of England they got some wind
farms that are happening and you know
can power four hundred and seventy
thousand homes there's huge wind farms
you know in the u.s. it's climbing
rapidly and also there's also a huge
increase in clean jobs so you guys this
is that I think this is the industry
that you guys should be getting into and
it just shows the spike even in 2012 of
all the solar installations that's
happening they had to wait a little bit
with the battery stuff but you know in
Africa they're actually putting up I'm
sorry Bangladesh they have little solar
panels for each home and so you can and
they're going up by the rate of one per
minute huge solar farms here and and I'm
not sure where this is like the oats in
Pakistan Pakistan has huge in solar you
know they're putting up these huge
Bangladesh and Pakistan are putting up
huge solar farms this is
chilly this is Honduras you know all
these small companies see that they're
there there's money in it also you got
the the battery that Tesla is putting
out the power wall for homes and this is
our blue planet again and here's me and
my penguin suit so I'm going to take a
couple questions now that you guys might
have and then I have a few questions
that some of the people have sent me to
so but if anybody has any questions at
this time I'm happy to answer them yes
can you please tell the class that some
work here at the very beginning what
you're doing in pairs well I go around I
do talks a lot of them are climate
focused because of my background I'm
really a data collector I go and I
collect data I'm not a scientist but I
truly have seen what's going on
especially in the Arctic the Antarctic
I'm not completely convinced I see water
temperatures changing by probably one
degree which changing krill populations
which is changing wildlife movement all
the krill is relying on or all the
wildlife is relying on krill up on the
down in Antarctica so I'm seeing
differences that haven't been noticed
before i'm seeing penguins not going
back to the same place they always go
back to the same place to breed they got
their mates for life i'm seeing
differences with that but the Arctic
Greenland Iceland svalbard northern
Canada Alaska all of Siberia and there's
not a lot of population around Siberia
and not a lot of research has been going
on there but that's really where the
impact is happening anyway tribes are
are having to change their whole focus
on on their way of life and so I'm off
to Paris to a called road to Paris and
all the world leaders are meeting on the
last week in november in the first week
in december and try to come up with a
climate solution it's basically a big
think tank with all our leaders and
hopefully we can come up with some
sort of resolution or at least some
rules we tried to do it a few years back
in Kyoto Keota and Kyoto Protocol which
most of the European nations saw that
that was something that they needed to
do a lot of the there's Norway and
Germany and Holland are all in the
forefront of this they've been using
tons of renewables and on that track
China is now starting to do a lot more
renewables clean energy they're one of
the biggest coal burners and on our
planet I'm actually seen suit up at the
North Pole from China so you know it's
there they see that there's money in it
India is a huge country that really
needs to change their their ways with
more renewable energy and cleaner energy
so we will i will talk to on a panel on
some of the world leaders and hopefully
we come up with some sort of plan
hopefully in a more of a recip plans
especially the u.s. it really I'm
anxious to see what's going to happen
next year with our election just with
the powers-that-be who's running our
company there's been a few things I
think the Obama administration has
really done some nice things in this
last eight months to really showcase
that he is a climate leader but there
are a few things that he's done that I
haven't agreed with it was a little bit
contradictory as well but luckily the
pipeline didn't go through they ended up
pulling it anyway so but yeah I go
around I was in Miami a couple weeks ago
at a climate convention doing some talks
i go to talks around about Shackleton
and you know about my expedition so it's
not just that but I am I am passionate
about our climate and I do think we need
to do something now and you know it's
not going to be in my lifetime but it's
it's your lifetime in our your kids
lifetime that really is is going to be
impactful and you know we are destroying
our planet so question
cut on your question under explore is
there any like contingency plans without
no plans just in case something wrong
you know it's I talk to the scientists
and they think you mean contingency plan
with climate change or on my on my
expedition fears oh well there's always
a plan for sure you mean if you fell in
or something like that or something
would go wrong I mean there's definitely
a plan in place that we have depending
on the environment that I'm in whether
I'm on the Arctic Ocean there's protocol
that we use and there's SAT phones and
we talked about that and extraction
methods I've fallen in before I had a
climbing all the way on the other side
so what happened is I was three-quarters
of a way across the lead and I ended up
falling in I got skis on I don't want to
lose my skis so I basically on the ice
here and I take my poles and I break the
ice and go back to the client I was like
right I only had two go three feet and
I'd be on the other side but it would be
no good for me to be on the other side
and him over here and I'm there so I
break the ice and go back that way
toward the client soon as I got out of
the water I took my skis off or tried to
get them off they started freezing the
boots froze to the binding system that I
had and I rolled in the snow to try to
absorb all the water if I could and then
I immediately set up a tent I ran around
the ten about 140 times to try to
generate heat I put him in the in the
tent and turned on the stove peeled off
my clothes put a couple I'd sub tent
clothes that I bring and I put those on
and I tried to dry the mitts in the in
the boots those are the things i was
going to need that was going to make me
stay warm and safe for the rest of the
trip so i spent about 15 hours drawing
the liners of the boots over the stove
and the mitts try to dry them out and it
was funny because the jacket was like
had it would look like body armor it was
just sitting in the vestibule the tent
when I took it off and because it was
all frozen and just like hanging there
wouldn't even roll up or anything so but
that that was you know I spent 15 hours
drawing all my
and luckily I'd brought enough fuel to
have that contingency plan you know
because if I'm you I'm usually you know
down but down to the wire with enough
fuel enough food for survival and if I
know that I'm running out of food and we
have 20 days left it's really a simple
equation I know in the first week
whether we're going to make it or not
because I have this much food this much
fuel in this much distance to get so if
i don't get 10.2 nautical miles today
and every day after that we're not going
to make it an equation changes if I
don't get that and obviously your sleds
going to get lighter and you're going to
move faster because you're going to get
fitter and that kind of thing but you
have to think about that you know and
you know whether you're going to make it
or not so yeah I've come across a
75-pound meteorite that's probably worth
over you know 50 million dollars and I
see it right there and the last thing I
want to do is put in my sled and haul 75
pounds across the Antarctic continent so
and you know it's a meteorite because
it's a white surface there's probably
meteorites right out here and in the
hills here but you you walk by them and
it's just a rock you know so what
happens is you end up a cruise in and
it's a white surface if it's not a
marine area you see a black rock and the
on the ice and you can almost guarantee
it's a meteorite so good what give you
as far as carbon offsets go it's really
great great question and that's one of
the questions someone asking me how do
you justify going there and bringing
these people and using the carbon
footprint because I'm flying and using
huge amounts of carbon to to fly these
places I do a couple things I have a
carbon offset company okay I also feel
that I am be making everybody
ambassadors for these places to preserve
and protect ok and that's my biggest
thing is to teach people on these trips
to showcase what's happening and what's
going on and hopefully they become
ambassadors for these places so I do
feel it's an impact I try to be as
stealth as possible i use a lot of
sailboats and
I have the least carbon footprint that
we can but I'm guilty of it you know I
am I mean I I try I Drive a hybrid you
know I mean that doesn't do anything
that only curves my gas a little bit i
still gotta drive up in Lake Tahoe and
with three feet of snow and stuff like
that so we all have to do our part you
know I think we take the small steps and
to really make a difference i think we
you contact your local local
representative whoever we whoever we put
in office and say here's here's some
plan that i really want you guys to work
on making making our government a lot
more clean and renewable I mean we're
the government and the and the armed
forces are one of the biggest polluters
and on the planet you know so yeah I
have a little bit of issue with it but I
feel that my work offsets it turn off
these questions with how did the blind
guy is a story behind the blind guide
you to give that back they've been doing
some other stuff together um he he holds
all kinds of records he flew an
ultralight from London to Sydney and
he's done the marathon des sabul that's
seven marathons in seven days and across
the Sahara he's done I don't know he's
done a bunch of stuff and he always does
it with John and it's his site guide so
and he's just happens to be deaf and
then a couple times he's in the tent and
he's trying to get out of the tent he's
stepping on the stove and I'm yelling at
him and he can't hear me it was like
almost your pictures yet you know you
got patches like World Wildlife
Foundation and stuff could help medicine
on one yet ben jerry's patch what
they're interested arm they were i
actually worked with ben and jerry's in
a couple different projects they did a
climate change college in Greenland and
i instigated that it was sort of an idea
that i had to educate youth about our
planet and they came and we went to
Greenland and I took some students
unfortunately been Jerry
didn't take it on here in the United
States they end up doing it in the UK
and Holland and my partner ended up
running most of it but it was my
original idea but it's okay i mean as
long as they're educating people i don't
know why they didn't do it in the
state's it was maybe because the
demographic is not what they were trying
to build their brand a little bit more
in in the UK and in Holland but uh I've
worked with them on several projects in
fact they're backing something else
right now another climate change thing I
read recently I can't recall them but uh
yeah you know you find sponsors that
believe in in what you're going I work
with European satellite agency I worked
with you know a bunch of different
Alfred venga Institute in Germany I work
with you know a lot of climate change
scientists in fact a lot of time you
know we'll bring back data and then I
want to know I talked to him because I
want to know be able to talk to you guys
are ticket Leah bout what's happening
and so I want to be able to know the
right information and it is fairly
complex you know as you know and you're
learning allows you to you know doing
these expeditions for a second really
hardcore skier here and what no I I
honestly wanted to go climbing ski
Vinson which is the high speaking
Antarctica 16,000 77 feet up put a team
together I before that I was I went to
shaman II and live for a couple springs
and shaman e is the birthplace of ski
mountaineering or climbing and so I was
like blown away by you know I'm climbing
ice with skis on my back and like what
we're going to ski this to how are you
going to ski it and you know we set up
an anchor and we repeal that section and
then ski on and keep on going and I was
like wow this is really cool and so I
and I've done a bunch of stuff up in
Alaska in the early 90s and what usually
in helicopters and sort of got over that
and about 95 I said I just wanted to
give in to ski touring and ski
mountaineering and that's I did and but
99 I wanted to go do the first ski and
snowboard to send vinson massif and what
I didn't realize is I really fell in
love with the continent
and at first moment that I step foot on
the ice runway and it was minus 40 and
blowing 40 miles an hour and there was
like crystals in the in the air and from
the ice and it was just blown blew me
away and then I walked about a hundred
meters and there was a tent city and a
guy making crepes and strawberries at
four in the morning you know and I was
like this where am I you know and we had
a great successful trip skiing Vincent
and and with a great bunch of friends
and that really got me involved and I
wanted to see more of Antarctica and
nothing lives in the interior so I was
in the interior for that one and then
two months later I charted a russian
research vessel went down to the
Antarctic Peninsula I explored down
there and that was like full of Wildlife
you know millions of penguins and seals
and whales and blew me away and this
diversity of like so much wildlife and
so much just really no wildlife you know
just the contrast of the beauty of the
Interior and the beauty of the peninsula
I wanted to learn more and so I was dumb
enough when they I didn't really know I
was getting into when I started my trip
with miles and John cross it with the
blind guy and deaf guy but you know I
think you learn a lot about yourself
because it's sort of like going on a
long run you have a lot of time for
meditation and thinking about things but
it's pretty remarkable if you do it for
62 days you know how you can really I
almost came back almost energized and
new ideas for trips and expeditions and
changing my life and doing things I mean
it's it's pretty remarkable how you can
really be ultra focused when you go out
and do these type of things yeah
scholarship yes okay given my fieldwork
in both Arctic and Antarctic I wish I
could attend Doug stop seminar here is
my question for Doug and it has a lot to
do with the role of tourism in raising
awareness to climate change in the polar
region should should we try to make
these regions more accessible to
visitors or
them to reduce direct environmental
damage from humans and ship traffic my
answer to that is there is tourism board
antarctic treaty is will be up in 20 41
and that is the year where all the
countries that have bases there will
decide what we do with it I am there's
all kinds of natural resources that we
could definitely exploit if necessary I
want to keep it clean and pristine I
want to make it a world park that's my
goal is to try to to to get a movement
to make it a world park for just
exploration and also for for science and
I think by bringing people there I think
the the Antarctic Tourism Board
maintains that they try to keep it safe
within within a reason they only allow
so many boats that I have to do all
kinds of permits and protocol to make
sure i'm american company so i go
through the EPA which are probably one
of the biggest polluters and that's one
of my pet peeves too wide we have all
these scientific basis in Antarctica
that they basically have six months of
Sun and they all have 365 days of wind
and they don't use any of it you know
you're pulling 432 flights in from
McMurdo Sound into the South Pole full
of fuel you know it doesn't make any
sense and they don't leave with any
other ways they just dug a big hole and
they'll give me a hard time if I'm going
a climbing expedition in Queen Maud land
and I'm with three people and like what
are you going to do you need to bring
everything out okay I'll do that but
what are you doing you know so these are
the same people I'm actually talking to
about it and you know i'm working on a
blog on the huffington post right now
and i'm questioning whether i should try
to exploit some of these things because
i think people should know but i also
they're in charge of letting me go
they're like the gatekeepers so who
knows i think i might just go forward
press the press the button and go ahead
and do it but i know a lot about what's
going on in some of these remote areas
that a lot of people don't see
your your experience working with
tourism board down there what is the
challenge of working in a place like
Antarctica where there's no one country
with full jurisdictional power we're
going to go all over it you know I can
be when you look at for example pull out
or Rapa Nui more recently with chili the
decision to eliminate industrial line
fishing in there Elsie's that's the
simple things that it's that most of my
lateral or maybe a multilateral and
we're that they achieve with other
countries but in Antarctica your
spelling there's no such there's no one
power down there so what the challenge
working in well I think it's the that
goes back to every bureaucratic
government to I mean we we operate a
base in the interior of Antarctica and
work with adventure network
international and we had a completely
solar wind and the only thing we left
was gray water and this was a huge base
that had the second largest air operator
next to the US government and we
probably had over 350 visitors every
winter every summer our winter their
summer and we would bring all the waste
back even our our feces and urine and
everything and all our trash you get to
Chile they just dump it right in the
ocean you know it's like okay we brought
it all the way back let's do something
with it and then you end up because it's
sort of out of sight out of mind there
you know but i think the antarctic
tourism board is really on the tourism
part they want to maintain that you're
not stressing the wildlife so there's
only so many people that can go visit
each penguin rookery known penguin
rookery they can only have so many boats
there is fourteen thousand and twenty
thousand people going there every summer
our Arctic Antarctic summer so there is
a lot of people going down there that if
you are on a big cruise ship with 3,000
people no one could go shore so it's
more of the small boat operators where
they only allow a hundred people at one
time to go to any any one location for
my trips it's not an issue because we
have a hundred skiers but we're going
places where no one's ever been to
before and we probably have for people
that want to go check out the penguin
rookery that everybody else goes to
weird
skiing down to all the other penguins
that no one goes to so I'm one of the
cleanest people put on another front I
those boats usually go to two or three
stops a day I go to one so I'm cutting
back on fuel costs so I don't use as
much fuel but we use a lot of zodiac
fuel which is the rubber zodiac boats
that we cruise around in because we're
going all over the place but you know we
we don't we don't go the bathroom on
shore we make sure we're not eating on
shore we're not sure we're trapped
putting any trash we try all we leave
his set of ski tracks and that's that's
our sort of motto and what we believe in
and we make sure that all the the
clients know that and make sure that we
follow all those rules so I think have I
seen an impact of people there not
really I mean I think I think there's
more impact with the water temperature
changing then there is with people to be
honest with you but on it there's no
sign of human beings in any of the
penguin rookeries or anything you might
see a you know a footprint in some mud
or something like that but when I go
down there's usually pretty good
snowfall around so it's a it's pretty
pretty uneventful you wouldn't think
that anybody was even there and I
usually go early in the season 2 i'm
usually one of the first boats down
there and i like that for a reason
because there is no there there isn't a
lot of traffic down there there's
probably only two or three other boats
that are there and i need to be able to
be be able to move around say if i want
to go skiing in this one area and all
the ice conditions have brought the ice
in and i can't get ashore safely i need
to have plan b c d and e goes back to
what you were saying you know so i have
to be up at four in the morning with the
captain if everybody if i get up at
seven o'clock and we've been hanging out
outside where we couldn't get in through
the ice captain's like on into where you
want me to go I have to be proactive
with in that decision-making to make
sure that we're at seven o'clock
everybody gets up and we're off going
skiing somewhere so
anyway another question okay over the
years you've been doing these sorts of
adventures how have technology
technological developments change the
lifestyle you lead while in the back
Reggie are their gadgets you can imagine
that you wish someday would make any
issues that are perpetual problems that
seem like they should have relatively
straightforward solutions well I mean I
showed one thing I think it was the the
a vtec was a was a good example of that
you know they're coming technology is
actually moving forward with analyzing
snowpack and that kind of thing I mean
I've lost numerous friends to avalanches
and knock on wood I love the mountains I
love to travel in the mountain so I
think we're very lucky here and the
Sierra Nevada mountains where we get a
type of snow that's its maritime which
means it has a lot of moisture in it so
usually after about 24 hours it
solidifies pretty pretty in a very
bonding way but you can't get complacent
about it and get plan on okay it's going
to be good because it's in the Sierra
Nevadas and just sort of like okay no
big deal you really still check it I dig
pits four or five times when I'm
climbing terrain that hasn't been skied
I listen to I don't have headphones on
and I'm not just listening to music as
I'm going up I listen to the mountains I
listen to the snow I listen to my
environment and try to be in touch with
my environment to make you know good
decisions to mitigate risk so all those
things are incorporated within my
decision making and I have no problem
turning around
the Antarctic would you like to does
anybody go there during that time yeah
well Antarctic winter is brutal it's
dark 24-7 temperatures get down to minus
70 I haven't been there in the winter so
there is scientists that work there
there's probably a thousand people
American scientists that work at McMurdo
was 52 scientists at work at the South
Pole and contrast in the summer there's
256 people working there in the summer
months and the winter guys are probably
drinking coffee all day and going crazy
because they got these huge Hubble
telescopes and it's a perfect
environment because they're looking into
the winter sky dark it's dark there's no
water vapor because you're at 9,000 feet
and it's usually clear and you got this
high-powered telescope looking back to
308 hundred and sixty million years past
the big bang theory and discovering a
galaxy every day you know so they're
probably sitting there sipping coffee
going yahoo you know loving life and so
they're doing some cool work I mean I'm
sure they're not outside for very long
they even have transportation like vans
and stuff that they keep running the
whole winter they never even turn them
off and they just run them back from the
main you know living quarters out to the
telescope and back it's really
interesting the buildings in the size of
the buildings there's no real you know
when you're skiing to the pole you don't
really see a pole you see these
buildings from sometimes two and three
days before you even get there but
there's no reference point you can't you
don't you see these like objects in the
horizon but there's no it's not like
there's a car a big tractor or anything
to have a reference point so you just
keep on skiing for you know 48 hours or
whatever and they just seem to not get
any bigger and uh because they're on
stilts noon I mean they did build a nice
base there I just wish they would have
used some renewables lots of fuel
run that bass so and it's a really
remote place to get it there so it's
expensive and the reason they made that
decision was because of government
contracts and they were all oil-based
government contracts so let's make sure
we run fuel there
you